I'm just I'm just grateful for my kids
you know what I mean some always have
like that respect for them you know and
vice versa that's all I ask for is
respect Blac Chyna showing love to X's
Rob Kardashian and Tyga it's really
definitely uh been an experience like
I'm really like grateful China got
candid on Sirius XM Sway in the morning
as she does press rounds to discuss what
she called her healing Journey this part
of my life is like really important you
know I'm changing you know and I want to
grow old with my kids China who's Now
using her birth name Angela White is
documenting everything about the
experience online that includes and
doing a number of cosmetic procedures
she's had over the years I'm tired of
the look and it's just not flattering
it's just not what I look like it like
totally changed my face and I'm just I'm
ready to get back to Angela like Blac
Chyna like black China is black China
you know what I mean and I feel like
I've outgrown that yeah and it's just
time for like a change how their fathers
supported you in this transformation and
that's where her exes come in she of
course shares children with both men
taika is Dad's routine year old King
Cairo robbed to six-year-old dream you
know what I haven't heard anything yet
okay yeah but I'm pretty sure that they
see it and and you know every day we're
changing you know we're getting older
and I'm just I'm just grateful for my
kids you know what I mean some always
have like that respect for them you know
and vice versa that's all I ask for is
respect she has discussed her lifestyle
changes with her kids though so when I
came back from my surgery they're like
so why you laying like that I'm like
Mommy just had surgery and they're like
so what'd you get I was like I got my
boobies and my butt smaller they're like
okay so uh they're like okay and then
when dreams saw my nails she was like
your nails because she looks up to me
and and every time she's like I can't
wait till I get oldest I could get long
nails mommy I'm like Dream Is Gonna Come
so now when she sees my nails now she's
like
oh you have short nails like I like your
nails Belle's Nails apparently sending
an important message to dream
so it's more like relatable to her and
like showing her that you don't have to
have long nails because right now I feel
like anything that I do they're like
real sponges now and they're gonna be on
to me yeah you know what I mean they
know like you know spelling out the
curse words they know how to spell quite
well and they catch on to everything oh
my God like they're amazing yeah yeah
they're doing well they're doing well
for sure ask for what's next seems like
Angela is sticking to focusing on
herself are you seeing a difference in
your attraction to men based off of the
transformation that you're having
honestly that's not even my focus and
that used to be my focus yeah you know
what I mean I'm not worried about that
right now I'm worried about me
like it's all about me hey man you feel
me and I like that I like that a lot
[Music]